I haven't been to church in like
almost 5 months because I have been so sick this pregnancy.
But tomorrow
I'm gonna try and go to church for the first time in since June.
Beginning of June. So help me pick out what I'm gonna wear,
because I do not know. Three head covering options have beige.
This is a sage e green. It's not this muted in person,
and a light dusty pink.
I want to wear something that kind of shows off the bump
because no one has seen me since I got pregnant.
I have this dress which I love and I think would show off the bump
and this dress, which I don't think would show off the bump as much.
Maybe if I put a belt with it.
I have this red dress which looks amazing on me,
but I also have red hair, so I don't wear it so much.
I have this dress which I really like,
and I think it would show off the bump,
but it's patterned,
so I don't think we'd be able to see the bump as much.
I have this dress which I love cause it's florally,
but I really don't know how much the bump would show.
Tell me which dress and which head covering I should wear. Help me out.